I'm gonna do two things here what I want
to do is explore this unordered
selections ID but in two particular
applications that maybe are a little
less than obvious okay so here's my
first one here's a scenario for you and
you've been asked ones like this in your
exercises but I just want to draw a nice
corollary is what they say they call it
out of it
suppose you have seven people right
seven people and you want to choose five
of them to be on a I don't know on a
team soon represented counsel you want
to choose five some people have been
asking me how can I tell like a part
from oh I'm in an exercise where this is
what I'm supposed to doing how can I
tell where the autumn matters or whether
it doesn't matter
is it a permutation or a combination you
have to pay close attention to language
basically if I am picking a team for
instance or a group then picking say
these five one two three four five
doesn't matter which ones which
well no there isn't a first or a second
or third or something like that if I
said to you I'm picking a captain and
vice-captain and etc ah
now suddenly which one is which does
matter okay but if I said five players
going to be chosen out of a seven using
our new notation what would we say for
this what would be our way of
calculating the answer you'd say seven
seven see five seven options choose five
of them okay now what I want to call
your mind back to you just like we did
this a lesson is that we learned
something about this from binomial
theorem okay namely that if you have a
look at Pascal's triangle okay this is
the same 75 is equal to because of the
symmetry of Pascal's triangle it's also
equal to 72 do you remember this okay
now you can show this in a very easy way
just on the definition the factorial
definition of what 75 is right and this
is what you might want to write down 75
is a 7 factorial on on what what's on
the denominator what factorials are
there 2 factorial 5 factorial right
whoops there's the ex-commissioner but
you can clearly see if you think about
this guy well it's gonna have the same
numerator and it's also gonna have the
same denominator right except you just
wrote it in a different order because
you thought of it from a different
right that's a that's a definition sorry
that's a proof from the factorial
definition but there is an even simpler
what we call a combinatorial proof a way
of thinking about this situation that
tells you exactly the same information
right I'm choosing five people to be on
my team right choosing five people to be
on the team can you see is identical to
choosing two players to be off the team
does this make sense like choosing those
two who are not on will give you exactly
the same result as this again the way we
would say this in fancy mathematical
terms is there is a one-to-one relation
between the players who off the team and
the players who are on the team you
might as well have chosen two people and
said okay let's just go home I've got
the five people that I want you people
can just go off okay does that make
sense
so this same idea which we met through
pass was triangle and through the
binomial coefficients it's got a
combinatoric reasoning underneath it as
well and often your ability to retell a
problem right which is what I'm about to
do over here
your ability to retell a problem can
often change it from being quite
complicated to being really simple now
can I ask all of you in your textbook if
you're not already in 10g go there and
I'd like you to have a look at question
13 with me because we're going to retell
this in a particular way to show you how
it's connected to all this unordered
selections business okay so 10j question
13 area you might find Pinchbeck my my
parents said okay thank you
top you can see it says here 10 points
are chosen in a plane no three of which
are collinear which is a bit of a
mouthful just on its own so you can see
what I've done here is I've drawn ten
points they don't actually have to be
here obviously they could be anywhere
but I've chosen these because it was
just a bit easier to make sure that they
would not be in a straight line three of
them in any particular way okay so
that's why they're roughly circular now
there's a set of questions here but the
first one says how many lines can be
drawn through pairs thank you of the
points how many lines can be drawn
through pairs of points okay now in
order to try and work out what's
happening here let's give these point
some names something that makes them
easy to handle and talk about here are
my 10 points each of which is labeled
now give me an example of one of the
lines that you could choose anyone any
random Jady Jady here it is
there's one of the Lions okay happy
times give me another one
it's not that hard really you can pick
any one you like so I said again be what
a B what do you know
Center G B G B G why not PJ here we go
right across the other side okay just
for the sake of completeness give me one
more one more
CH thank you okay oh there we go that's
very nice of you
okay now let me just repeat to you what
you just said to me I think I think you
said B G no I think he's a JD first in
you and then you said was the last one
CH okay so this is what you told me and
then this is what I drew okay now do you
see to create a line out of any two
points on there essentially what you
have done is out of ten possible letters
ABCDE F G H I J
you chose two of them do you agree this
geometric problem is exactly the same as
you have ten letters choose two of them
to make a two letter word they are
exactly the same problem which is why
their answers are also identical okay so
the way that you phrase this the way you
tell the story and the way you you know
draw a picture put it down will define
for you how exactly you answer the
question now I want to push on this why
is it ten C two for instance and not ten
P two
why is it this or not this what's the
difference between them the difference
is order where the autumn matters or not
so can you tell me now why doesn't order
matter in this situation nice in that
area for everyone here
okay so if I vary the order right DJ and
JD aren't the same line I've drawn both
of them right so therefore they are not
really different water is unimportant so
now when you have a look at Part B that
was part a right when you look at Part B
I think it's asking you about triangles
now isn't it
train was so here's a triangle for you
hmm
I'll just pick a couple of points you
haven't been used there's a triangle
it's a bad triangle but work with me in
order to create their triangle what did
I have to choose yeah I and F in this
case did B order matter no you could
just as easily have called it Fe I would
have been the same triangle right so in
order to work out the number of
triangles that I could form out of these
ten points it's not going to be a
tendency to it's going to be ten c3
because you just need three points any
three points and they'll give you a
triangle by the way that's why they make
that weird stamp in the beginning about
them not being collinear if there were
some points that were collinear you
couldn't do this could you because if
you pick three points that were
accidentally in a line you're like what
not much of a triangle right so that's
why they put that condition there so my
suggestion to you especially I mean I
put it on the screen before as you get
to some of those later questions it will
not be obvious you know what does this
what's the actual way you could tell the
story to make it easy to use ten CVS or
ten say that okay so think about the way
you can draw it phrase it write it down
so it becomes a problem that you know
how to solve okay